so texas church is almost certainly
going to get sued for an illegal
performance of the play hamilton because
they did it without authorization and
added a whole bunch of anti-gay
messaging
[Music]
this play is bad
extremely bad
and it's almost certainly copyright
infringement but as the original
playwright lin-manuel miranda said it's
never okay to change the words lyrics or
notes without their expressed consent
except that sometimes it is sometimes
commentary and criticism requires that
you change the word of someone else's ip
and these rules can't change whether you
like the message or not in fact in the
seminal case on fair use campbell versus
acuff rose the rap group two live crew
changed the words to roy orbison's song
pretty woman and it was considered
parody and it was considered fair use
now that probably doesn't apply here
this looks like straight up copyright
infringement it doesn't seem like it's a
parody but that being said parody
doesn't require you to agree with the
message and it's an argument to be made